it's been really really cool it's my
first time so I'm kind of excited about
everything not kind of i'm like really
excited there's a gigantic shark and I
love Shark Week so that's awesome I've
seen a lot of performers I performed
yesterday outside on the think they
called at the summer upload stage which
is cool really exciting I didn't expect
there to be so many people the day
before VidCon but it was a lot of fun um
I'm a youtuber and vid cause all about
YouTube so for me it's all about
networking meeting the people I see
online and just kind of figuring out how
we can collaborate work together and
just speaking on panels I just love
seeing everyone here because it becomes
a reality I know that people I make
videos for actual real people and not
just numbers so yeah I really had
minimal expectations not like I thought
it would suck like I just had no idea so
I just kind of left my mind open on it
but it's really interesting it's cool
like it's cool to see like those brands
and there's fun games as a giant shark
that I hope doesn't come to life and
some kind of weird you know magical play
I'd be terrible people are screaming
everywhere I never know what's happening
there's all these bloggers from the UK
that I don't know about that are getting
chased through the hotel it's cool topic
has been cool it's uh
it's been a little hectic I've never
done something like interview back to
back to back to back to back like this
ever before so it's like I always have
to check my calendar but its move I'm
feeling for don't know if I'm important
I'm really excited to meet Philip
DeFranco if I can ever get a chance to
bump into him which is it gonna happen I
think he's got like three body guards
walking around on the whole time Phil
DeFranco and I almost son I looked at
him it was weird but I got to go on I
got to go on SourceFed for an interview
I was like so nervous if you watch it if
you see the interview of me on sorts but
it's really embarrassing i'm like
standing there and I just like sweating
and they're like who should who are you
excited to see house like Phil DeFranco
this is awkward I'm sorry I would
probably just tell him that I think he's
a genius and that I really appreciate
the things that he's done for YouTube
and with YouTube and the work that he
continues to do on other platforms and
is I just can't wait to see what he's
got to do next I kind of admire him for
his ability to think outside the box
outside the screen I guess yeah there's
some video video people here that I'm
like you guys are super talented I'm
just like any time we can work together
looks good I went to the YouTube party
last night and was all like the top
people at Google and YouTube that like
program and make things happen so is
cool actually talking to them and see
them that actually care what we're doing
and they have a huge hand in what we're
doing they know who we are and
everything like that so that was a
really big deal for me um it seems like
it's much much busier and it was busy
last year I remember like looking around
going wow holy crap it's really packed
but this year I think it's definitely
more packed more crowded nothing really
do you know just being the fans that's
the best part about this is I'm you know
just seeing the people have you know
been supporting me for the last couple
years so it's really cool to you know
kind of put a face behind that behind up
people now is that [ __ ] or you
really mean that I look at the cameras
it I love the man I love the fans you
are one of the consummate Frank guys
obviously there's some others I can't
say the best I think you're all very
equal and awesome equal ok ok maybe not
i gotta do some catchy go wow there we
go romanatwood decided no well if you
know it's those things like he thinks
he's the best but of course littlest you
know that he's gonna quit YouTube Monday
I'm really looking forward to seeing
rahat it
is here he's that like the magic trick
guy on YouTube he does like a lot of
like different magic tricks and stuff
like that and he does a lot of really
like epic videos he collabs with Jack
Vale sometimes and I think he's going to
be here too I don't really care about
him but rahat he's gonna yeah I don't
know if you've ever seen jack vale
studios I've heard the name I'm not they
saw don't even waste your time